foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this session we will learn how to
eliminate duplicate rows in SQL but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if your attack geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's get started with a one
point agenda that is how to eliminate
duplicate records in SQL table now we
can eliminate the duplicate records in
SQL by a few methods so we will use the
most simplest ones the first one is
using the inner join along with a whack
loss and the second one is a sample and
the humble distant command now we have a
brief idea on the methods let's
understand them in a much more detailed
way through a practical demonstration
now let's get back to the MySQL
workbench to understand the codes in a
much better way so now now we are on the
MySQL workbench and we will get access
to our simply learn database and we are
in the simply learn database so
previously we used to work on our
employee table so let's not work on the
same employee table since we have actual
data there let's try to duplicate that
table so that we will have some
duplicate entries in between so we will
be changing the employee ID numbers and
we will also be using the same employee
ID numbers so the employee ID has some
detail to it so we'll be understanding
that in a much more detail while we are
executing the commands and we will also
try to remove the primary key from the
table so I'll also explain why we are
going to include the primary table and
also will explain the usage of
eliminating it so when you have the
primary key in the table SQL workbench
or any SQL will automatically stop you
from adding duplicated values but let's
say if you add a duplicate entry with a
new primary key right then it will not
stop you so we'll also have a
demonstration about what to do in such
scenarios so now let's try to quickly
create a duplicate employee table which
will be employee table 2 and then we
will try to add some duplicate entries
into it remember we will not use the
primary key here so the code will be
create
table
emply
ee table
two
and everything will be same which is
from the previous table which will be
the employee ID integer type employee
name character type this character type
pen code will be integer and normally we
include the primary key in this way
primary key brackets open
em
so this is the way how we add the
primary key but we are not going to add
it since we want to know what happens if
we enter data which also has the
duplication of the primary key right so
we will not give any primary key over
here
let's quickly run this
there you got the new duplicated table
of employee table has been created let's
try to insert the same values with some
duplication
there you go I have pasted the command
for inserting the values and if You
observe clearly at the end I have
repeated the values of Tony KT summer
June and Gloria so these five will be
the duplicate values and also we are
trying to enter the duplicated primary
key since we did not declare the ID as
the primary key it will accept all these
values let's quickly run this and there
you go the values have been successfully
entered into the table let's quickly see
if we have the duplication
select star
from
employee
table
enter there you go so you can see the
duplicate values are also added onto the
table now how do you remove these
duplications remember we discussed the
distinct one distinct method which is
the second one so that happens to be the
most simplest one let's see how it works
so here we will write a simple select
command
select
distinct
star
from the employee table 2.
now this will give us the distinctive
values
right but again when you run this
particular command which is Select star
you will have all the details back again
right our job is to eliminate them so
what we will do is we'll create a
duplicate table
so let's name it as the up table
so create table
duplicate table will be the name
now
quickly execute this command
and there you go now we have
the
data
which we obtained from the distant
command is stored into the table named
as duplicate table
now let's quickly drop the employee
table 2.
okay the table has been successfully
dropped
so when we run the same command once
again it says simply learn DB did not
find any table by the name employee
table 2 that means it's been eliminated
now the next thing we need to do is
rename it
so what we're trying to do is we are
trying to use the altar table and we are
trying to rename duplicate copy to
employee table 2 so that we have the
actual table here after eliminating the
duplicated values let's not do copy it's
actually Duke table
right
there you go
now let's execute this
successfully done now if we execute this
particular select command you can see we
have the cleaned data without any
duplicate entries this was one of the
simplest ways of eliminating duplicates
in a SQL table now let's try to get a
step ahead and try to use some join
commands and
where commands and where conditions and
using those we will try to eliminate the
duplications in a table now we are
talking about a table which does have
the you know primary key
and the data's will be duplicated let me
explain you how now let us declare
the
primary key as employee ID
e
s e m p ID
right now we do have a primary key now
there is no way okay let's try to create
this uh before that let's try to
truncate employee table 2
so we can use the
not the drop table we can use the
truncate so let's replace drop with
runki so that the data which we have an
employee table will be removed there you
go now
we will or let's quickly drop the table
because we are trying to create the new
table right so let's create the new
table
so once we have executed the drop table
command the table has been successfully
removed now let's try to create this
particular table
enter there you go 3 will get
successfully created now let's try to
duplicate the same entries remember I'm
not changing the primary key here
now when I run this command I will get
an error which says primary key cannot
be duplicated
so here you can see duplicate entry for
9 and you cannot have the duplicate
entries right this is one way to avoid
duplications but what if someone comes
up with a brilliant idea to replace the
primary key now if I change the primary
key
as
17 18.
let's say we also
have this data copy
let's duplicate
right this will be our 19 and this will
be R20 now we have unique
primary keys for Ola data and we also
know there are some duplications let's
try to execute this command and see the
output
so somewhere something is not correct
yet
look at this one
so Tony has been repeated so we can have
a different ID for Tony
let's say we have Tony as 21
try to execute the command once again
it should be clear now
okay it still has some duplication
somewhere
yes it's right here
let's keep this as 22.
okay I think we made a lot of
duplications somehow
let's quickly take a look at all the
major keywords are duplicated or not so
we copied from Gloria
so after Gloria we
we will remove these
so Gloria so we just make sure we're
trying to make sure that the primary
keys are unique here so 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20.
.
there you go so now we believe that all
the primary keys are unique let's try to
run this command and see if we get the
same error or not no so now all the data
has been inserted into the duplicate
table which is employee table 2 and we
also have some duplicate entries now how
would you recognize that we don't have
any duplicates or how would you
recognize which data has been exactly
duplicated and how do you even remove it
now the old distinct command is not
going to work
anyhow let's see if it works by any
chance so when I try to run the distinct
command it will give me all 22 rows with
all the duplicate entries right in this
case we can use the first method which
was the join and where condition method
right let's try to do that so we are
going to use the delete command
delete T1
from employee
table
to
T1
in a joint
in a join employee table 2 as T2 so we
are declaring two different tables so we
are
considering T1 as one table and T2 as
the next or second table so T1 and T2
are the copies of the same existing
employee table 2 right now we are
joining these two tables and we are
having a back condition over here so
from table T1 we're going to eliminate
table one from table 2 where we have an
intersection and where we have the
employee IDs greater than employee ID in
employee
okay let's not confuse so
let's execute the command first okay
let's
execute this to understand what I mean
here so here when we go a little down
you can see
14 for Tony right actual employee ID of
Tony is nine but we have 14 for Tony and
Gloria we have 18 19 20 and again for KT
we have 22 the actual number of KT is
10 right so now it will try to recognize
the highest number of employee ID so it
will recognize the highest employee ID
number and it will retain it and rest
all the numbers will be eliminated so
this is the first where condition and
we're also giving a string comparison
function where SQL will try to identify
if there is a similarity between the
employee name of the first table and the
employee name of the second table and we
know that when you give the string
comparison operation if it results in 0
it means the strings are equal if it
results in 1 it means the strings are
not matching now that we understood the
logic of this particular statement let's
try to execute it
so there you go so we have executed the
command now let's try to see what's left
in the table there you go now we should
be having the usual 13 number of
employees in our table and you can see
that the records are retained where the
employee ID number is the highest
remember we had the number 10 as
employee ID for KT and we have that over
here in case if you want the actual
numbers to be placed however they were
you can make a small change to your
command all you need to do is keep this
particular or change this particularly
greater than symbol to lower than symbol
and you will retain the actual numbers
of the employee records so that's how
you can eliminate the
duplicate entries in the table
and if you ask me
hey only two conditions are enough don't
you think the PIN code and you know we
also have PIN code and the address of
the employees don't you think that is
also important yes you can also do that
you can make some minor modifications to
your code and try to include all those
remaining things and again you can do
the same right now let's try to
eliminate the data in our table let's
truncate it and we should be having no
data left in our table and let's try to
insert the duplicate entries once again
and okay before that let's try to do
this particular execution remember we
try to keep the employee ID let's try to
execute that and try to print it and we
should be having the actual numbers over
here right as expected
now let's again truncate the data and
try to compare the conditions or we will
be using the where condition and we'll
have all the parameters included in our
condition let's truncate the table and
let's try to add the duplicate entry so
once again
there you go we have all the duplicate
entries enter now what we will be doing
is we will be using the same command but
the only change will be the string
comparison or the where condition right
so you can keep this string comparison
if you want or if you can change that
let me change that actually
so instead of
this we will use this particular command
where we are trying to compare the
employee ID so let's keep the employee
ID as
lesser than so that we have the actual
employee ID numbers and we are using an
and condition over here so that uh this
particular condition should be valid and
the employee name should be equal to the
employee name in T1 and T2
and the next one is here we have the
employee address so the employee address
in T1 and T2 should also be same and pin
code from both the table should also be
seen so what we are trying to compare
here is we are trying to keep the
employee ID with the least number or the
least value and the names of the
employee should be same the address of
the employee should be same and the PIN
code of the employer should be seen in
that particular condition you can try to
delete the record let's try to execute
this and there you go the command got
executed and now let's try to execute
the select command which should give us
the final result
so here you go control enter and you
have the data here so now we have
successfully eliminated all the
duplicates by comparing the values in
each and every single column and we also
have reading the original ID of each and
every employee now that's how you try to
eliminate duplicates in SQL tables and
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources like PPT and
code executed then do let us know in the
comment section below and RTM effects
password will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here